game over das spiel ist aus steht da
geschrieben baden bord heißt diese firma
im herzland des deutschen mittelstands
hieß muss man wohl sagen
280 frauen und männer haben zum
jahreswechsel beim kartonhersteller
ihren arbeitsplatz verloren einer von
ihnen ist hans peter schonert 43 jahre
lang ist er hier schaffen gegangen ich
bin jetzt 62 das wird richtig schwierig
ich will was machen ich bin fit ich bin
körperlich top kann viele nur meine alle
da macht man halt weiter spricht durch
die rechnung und dann zieht sich wieder
den deutschen staat auf der tasche wir
sind den gernsbach im murgtal bei baden
baden die region lebt vom papier es
waren vor allem die energiepreise die
beiden bord in die knie gezwungen haben
eine million euro pro woche hätte der
neue käufer im januar für das gas
bezahlen müssen da hat der reißaus
genommen und platz gemacht für den
insolvenzverwalter
wir hatten kunden an bord mitarbeiter
die motiviert waren aber wir hatten
keine
ausreichenden mittel um diesen enormen
gaspreis den wir vor finanzieren müssten
die waren die mittel nicht vorhanden
aufgrund der kriegsgefahr mit russland
und dem aufleben der asiatischen märkte
nach der pandemie ist das gas immer
teurer geworden dazu steigende kosten
für den klimaschutz die die wirtschaft
umweltfreundlicher machen sollen in der
summe hat dass die kartonfabrik und 280
beschäftigte die zukunft gekostet
diese dramatik und die
unvorhersehbarkeit dass es tödlicher und
speziell für den mittelstand tödlich
weil der eben nicht die rücklagen und
die möglichkeiten hat von einem großen
konzern
steigende energiepreise treffen
praktisch jeden in den vergangenen zwölf
monaten sind die für strom gas und erdöl
an den börsen in die höhe gerast so
stieg der strompreis um fast 300 prozent
der kurs für erdgas um 75 und der für
erdöl um 68 prozent
was für die wirtschaft und verbraucher
ein preisschock ist füllt dem start die
kassen geschätzt fast eine milliarde
euro mehr an steuern
die bundesregierung hat angekündigt
menschen mit wenig geld mit einer
einmalzahlung zu entlasten doch das ist
nur ein bruchteil der mehreinnahmen gibt
planungen die wirklich an die
bevölkerung weiterzugeben bisher
betrifft das er mit empfängern von
wohngeld
studenten etc doch er ausgewählte kleine
gruppen ja die bundesregierung ist
darauf bedacht dass die entlastung die
aufgrund der gestiegenen preise auch
spürbar sein soll nicht mit der
gießkanne passiert sondern sozial
ausgestaltet wird die steuern auf
energie müsse der staat sofort senken
fordert die opposition
es reicht nicht aus der staat hat mehr
einnahmen durch gestiegene energiepreise
die müssen jetzt den bürgern
zurückgegeben werden und deshalb
brauchen wir mehr entlastung als das was
die ampel bisher auf den weg gebracht
hat der staat darf nicht an gestiegenen
energiepreisen verdienen doch an jedem
gas laster verdient der staat mit 25
prozent steuern und abgaben
rentner und geringverdiener sind bisher
bei der entlastung nicht vorgesehen
menschen wie vitalis die pensionierte
kindergärtnerin muss ihren tank jetzt
befüllen lassen sonst wird es kalt für
die 78 jährige die fürchtet dass die
kosten durch die co2 bepreisung noch
weiter steigen und fordert dass die
regierung dagegen etwas tut
steuern die öko steuern und das nicht
alles an uns
abgegeben wird dass mir das alles tragen
müssen sie hätten ja vorher schon mal
ein bisschen mit der energiewende
anfangen können und den ökostrom vorher
schon steuern können
verbraucher wie gitarrist sollten am
besten ganz weg vom gas wünscht sich
wirtschaftsminister habeck wie die
menschen im land das aber bezahlen
sollen ist vielen ein rätsel und durch
die beschlossene co2 verpressung werden
ja die preise langfristig deutlich
weiter steigen gibt es da überlegungen
noch mal ran zu gehen es ist hier
vorgesehen
dass ein energie geld eingeführt wird
und dass die mehreinnahmen aus der co2
bepreisung eingehen
wäre dass die antwort auf ihre frage
oder man zusatz dazu gibt es denn
mittlerweile konkrete planungen wie
dieses energie geld ausgezahlt werden
soll das war ja im vergangenen jahr doch
noch sehr vage die bundesregierung
befindet sich dort in einer abstimmung
die noch nicht so weit sich manifestiert
dass da schon was substanzielles zu sagt
sozusagen ist aber dass es fest
vorgenommen aber konkretes kann ich
ihnen dazu noch nicht sagen doch die
zeit drängt beim wohnen steigt der
energieverbrauch stetig den
milliardensubventionen für sanierungen
zum trotz seit 2010 von
673 auf 7 122 milliarden kilowattstunden
ein anstieg von über sieben prozent
dabei ist gas der mit abstand wichtigste
energieträger der verbrauch erhöhte sich
sogar um 16 prozent
das hat auch der teams in kiel leidvoll
erfahren
2014 hat der rentner begonnen über die
energetische sanierung seines hauses
nachzudenken die energie berater kamen
und gingen infrarot bilder zeigten die
energetischen schwachstellen und siemens
investierte insgesamt 20.000 euro
wir haben wir die gesamten fenster im
haus erneuert oder auch isoliert leser
einbauen lassen entwicklungs fenster
ausgetauscht und und nicht wir haben
hohe wand dämmung machen lassen nicht
bis hin dass wir also die die steckdosen
haben isolieren lassen dann wird also
auch kein zug mehr irgendwie aus den
händler schnitten bereichen kommt so
nicht alles haben wir gemacht und hatten
kein geld gekostet aber wenn ich auf
unsere abrechnung kugel dann stelle ich
eigentlich fest das bringt uns nichts
die politik hat menschen wie siemens
immer wieder angespornt zu investieren
gebracht sagt er habe ihm das praktisch
nichts um die gestiegenen energiekosten
stemmen zu können hat er einen teil
seines hauses zur ferienwohnung gemacht
und wird in zukunft womöglich mehr platz
abgeben müssen
und wissen sie was das erinnert mich an
meine kindheit das war der
nachkriegszeit nicht damals war das
nicht so dass wir energie probleme
hatten sondern werden damals so wenig
wohnraum aufgrund der ganzen
bombardierungen der städte und da fühle
ich mich irgendwie
massiv daran erinnert wenn ich heute die
aus anderen gründen in diese gleiche
lage komme ich muss raum vermieten den
hier mit anderen leuten teilen bloß
damit ich meine energie kosten tragen
kann das ist ein witz in sich
zurück ins murgtal zur kartonfabrik
baden bord die ist geschichte und mit
ihr 280 arbeitsplätze
energieintensive branchen wie papier
aluminium und die autoindustrie prägen
die region
der insolvenzverwalter sieht die am
scheideweg man wird vielleicht einfach
davon ausgehen müssen dass sich in
deutschland die landschaft
industrielandschaft ändert und
energieintensive unternehmen hier nicht
mehr wirtschaftlich produzieren können
seit jahrzehnten ist es der mittelstand
der die menschen im südwesten
deutschlands in arbeit und zu wohlstand
bringt die energie krise hinterlässt ein
fragezeichen ob dieses modell noch eine
zukunft hat und ob es der
bundesregierung gelingt klimaschutz
wohlstand und soziale sicherheit
irgendwie in einklang zu bringen